outside right now you've got the cloud
well that's going to make a great sunset
look at that shot there this is our
camera looking at the las vegas strip
bit of a breeze outside right now at
this hour the high for the day today
here you go 86 degrees even with that
cloud cover we warmed up nicely 60 for
the overnight low 76 our average so we
were 10 above normal but nowhere near
that record of 94 back in 61. currently
outside we'll start off in the northwest
part of the valley 83 for you up there
in sky canyon centennial hills same for
spring valley 85 right now for north las
vegas 87 for whitney ranch green valley
included 83 henderson same for anthem
southern highlands and mountains edge i
think that's usually the popular number
right now right same for you in rhodes
ranch outside the valley warmer for you
look at death valley right now 80 40 not
94 degrees we'll only reach a century
mark tomorrow for sure 80 for prump 84
right now for those of you joining us
from boulder city so there's a cloud
cover this is our radar too but really
nothing on the radar giving us any rain
that's going to reach the ground all
that energy staying up in the idaho
there the idaho
panhandle there and some of the wasatch
but otherwise we'll get some clearing
from these clouds a little later on
tonight but expect some roller coaster
temperatures this week what we mean by
that is look at these numbers they go up
then they go down then back up again in
the 90s and then down again huge drop in
temperatures expected for early on next
week now remember next week is spring
bank for clark county so we're going to
show you what to expect coming up 63
degrees tonight overnight very mild
light breezes that's going to be a great
start to the morning mild start to our
morning 89 for tomorrow breezy and
warmer tomorrow
our normal 76 like we talked about
so way above average we'll see less
clouds for tomorrow a lot of
neighborhoods in those high 80s some of
you will touch the 90s like green valley
sunrise matter where you're lower in
elevation tends to be warmer 90 for
nellis 88 aleante 88 also spring valley
and we'll be at the century mark for
death valley look at that 100 degrees
tomorrow 87 for boulder city and 96 for
laughlin here is your eight day forecast
now we told you about those roller
coaster temps we will have breezy winds
for several days here on the eight day
even stronger wind for the weekend and
next week we drop into the 60s look at
that 64 on tuesday aviators tomorrow
opening day
705
75 i hope they play better than that
whistle
breezy and warm and you fight for gates
oh that's better there we go that was
much better but i can already smell the
burnt ends burritos
already by the way
he was using a whistle app none of that
was real no
the raiders we haven't heard much about
the raiders but we have heard from
devonta adams the wide receiver one of
the best reasons